hello hey as you just heard my name is
DL Stewart and I'm a faculty member here
on campus at Colorado State University
but what's most important for you to
understand about me right now is that I
identify as both black and as
transgender or trans and yes I'm going
to talk to you today about how black
trans lives matter as I do so I'm going
to share a few scenes from my own life
mixed in with the ways that race and
gender have historically and currently
intersected to shape the lives of black
trans people ready scene 1 I am at home
with myself my body a sovereign country
sovereign meaning it is superlative in
quality of the most exalted kind having
generalized curative powers of an
unqualified nature unmitigated paramount
possessed of supreme power unlimited an
extent absolute enjoying autonomy
independent royal my body defies the
restrictions of a society consumed by
boxes and binaries and are you a boy or
girl independent of such conventions my
body clings instead to the long-ago Lord
that understood its magic I contain
multitudes from this supreme power to
name myself define myself and be myself
I stake a claim to my self and organize
my resistance a resistance that boldly
proclaims that black trans lives matter
my body is a sovereign country and my
first sight of resistance
and seem to say that black trans lives
matter is a claim to sovereignty as much
as black girl magic and trans it's
brilliant black trans lives matter is
also a chorus of resistance because
black trans lives begin by defining our
bodies as sovereign countries from which
we first begin to resist the messages
that we have no place here we push whole
movements forward on the strength of our
vision we set trends and create new
worlds we are the band guard black trans
lives have always mattered and yet
caught at the time-travelling
intersection of Juneteenth emancipation
celebration and stone walls emancipation
declaration black trans lives are both
seen but yet unseen unseen by the anti
blackness of queer and trans movements
unseen by the transphobia and transient
agonism of black movements our
sovereignty and resistance are blocked
by layers of systems and structures that
have always thought to contain defined
and erase black trans bodies seem to I
am with my therapist the one whose
testimony I must rely on to declare me
man enough to have my documents changed
the one who is to be believed despite my
own declarations that I am NOT this body
that this body is neither hers nor yours
to define I sit with this doctor and she
fills out a form for me and when
considering what all I've done to affirm
my gender has the patient's gender
presentation
aligned with their gender identity she
decides that my gender presentation is
more neutral really while I sit there
mind you head to toe and clothing from
the section of the store where the dress
buttons go down the right side and my
pants give away the number of inches
around my waist and my hair is cut like
denzel's man on fire but I'm still more
neutral really because she still sees
and you see a black woman and black
women's bodies are always already made
gender less in seen from mammy and
Sapphire to mandingo and [ __ ] black
bodies and our genders have been caught
in the white imagination and the
imagination of whiteness is fanciful and
powerful enough to turn its fancies into
realities imagined as a thing we were
made to become that thing and so we have
been bred like horses fed like turtles
to alligators branded like cattle milked
like Sal's made into oxen to plow gender
did not matter so long as our body parts
our arms and legs and backs our breasts
and genitalia could be turned into
profit the black body was made not white
and therefore not worthy of gender and
under the weight of the genteel tool and
virginal lace that dressed plantation
mistresses black femininity has always
been denied
instead she is either beast or porn star
neither a proper gender dehumanized made
a social threat that endangers civility
that puts civilization in danger the
angry black woman cannot be a
skate not even by a first lady of these
united states
likewise ill-suited for chivalry and
outmatched as masters and captains of
fate black manhood lays flaccid in the
hands of white men's dominance body
measurements taken speed measured draft
pick forecasted this is the NFL Combine
body measurements taken teeth and body
cavities inspected number assigned this
is the prison intake room body
measurements taken talents and abilties
advertised teeth and body cavities
inspected name and value assigned this
is a slave's bill of sale made either
stud or farce he is not for his own
pleasure but rather for profit and jest
athletes and comics contained made not a
threat my gender is blacks at Harveys
odd because black bodies and our genders
have been caught in the white
imagination and we have always been
transgressive transgressive meaning a
violation of accepted and imposed
boundaries of social acceptability
blackness is transgressive and once set
free from social acceptability blackness
challenges the limitations of what
gender can be we have always been
fugitives here escaping from gender
surveillance to claim our sovereignty
and right to exist and to live free to
proclaim as beautiful that which was
made ugly to defy convention black lives
and trans law
and black trans lives and yet in this
world that fact that black trans lives
make a difference
make differences and make a matter of
mattering is doused by the fire hoses of
past and current denials of our rights
to exist and resist we must fight to be
seen as we see through fences into the
play yards we are kept out of scene
three I am at school the bell rings it's
recess we line up to go outside those
made boys on one side those make girls
on the other we file out of the doors
the boys stopping the fill in the closed
off Street the girls and I walking
across the street keep your eyes
straight ahead we are told because
there's a park across the street but
there is a wrought iron fence that
encloses that Park this is where the
girls and I play mostly I stand at the
fence and watch as my fellows play ball
in the street and be loud and be rough
and be sweaty and I am behind the fence
accused of thinking naughty thoughts
they have no idea
unseen sissified in bull daggered we are
all made-up just boys and dresses and
girls in suits the black transgressive
body caught in fantasies of boxes and
binaries that make our genitalia
representative of our gender and our
mannerisms our sexuality black trans
lives are therefore written off as
merely gay effeminate or lesbian butch
and the overlay of femininity on bodies
marked as male and therefore as man and
here's like a kick me sign is that the
consequences are much more deadly the
majority of trans people murdered in
this country are black trans women
because when manhood is located between
one's legs and defined in opposition to
womanhood what's between one's legs
cannot be seen as having anything in
common with womanhood and the same
acidic wash serves to blanch trans
masculinity making it fade into
nothingness black trans men become
illusions of manhood women merely
playing at being men because you can't
get a real man forever put in our place
we are indelibly marked as woman and
that best the looming threat of black
trans manhood is contained and knock you
lated made more neutral really seen for
I am with my therapist I tell her what I
think about if my body begins to slowly
morph into another version of itself
what will happen as I move from the
social threat of angry black womanhood
to the physical threat of looming black
manhood when will my neighbors forget to
recognize me and
i pitbull they've seen us nearly every
day pre-dawn or after Twilight for what
will have been over two years by then
when and how soon after I am no longer
misgendered woman will the cops be
called to come and contain and erase my
presence how soon before the purse
clutching the sidewalk crossing what
does it mean to become a brute to turn
my body into another kind of threat
she's stunned that I'm already
recognizing this I can't afford not to
and seen who can see me and my black
trans can in the skin we are in who
dares to love us who holds us close to
whom do we matter other than to
ourselves we're not looking for slave
saviors we have each other as little
Watson said if you have come here to
help me you are wasting your time but if
you have come because you recognize your
liberation is bound up in mind then let
us work together let us work together to
make black trans lives matter the lived
experience of black trans people out in
the world and if you believe that your
liberation is bound up with mine then I
invite you to make black trans lives
matter your personal ethic by being
transformative loudly and mindfully you
can do that in three ways transform your
thinking about blackness and gender be
loud by taking the risk to confront
false assumptions and others fears and
biases be mindful and pay attention and
believe what black trans people say
about our own lives being transformative
loudly and mindfully takes practice
just like getting someone's pronouns
right minor they/them/their and
he/him/his by the way and getting
someone's pronouns right and being
transformative loudly and mindfully
matters because black trans lives matter
my life matters
my body is a sovereign country and my
first sight of resistance
[Applause]
[Music]